hello ahs fans fx has graced us with a
preview for this thursday's upcoming
episode three and i thought i'd get all
my thoughts out there on what might be
in store for us but first if you haven't
seen the preview i've left a link to it
in the description so take a look and
come and meet me back under the dick
dock this video may contain spoilers for
episodes 1 and 2 and i encourage you if
you haven't seen my breakdown or my
trailer breakdown for the season to
check those out but let's get right into
this alright here we have harry looking
a bit concerned and considering what
he's been up to these last episodes i
would be too the machinery in the
background suggests he's in the hospital
most likely because of his wife in the
preview trailer we saw this image but
i'd be surprised if this happens this
early in the season the title of this
episode is thirst and the description
reads harry's newfound talent brings an
unexpected visitor to town alma decides
to take matters into her own hands the
unexpected visitor we can assume is
ursula who we see here in the preview
we've also seen her in some of the
earlier trailer footage with harry and
alma as well as getting close to mickey
trying to find out what the hell is
going on in town we then see elma
looking like she's gonna take matters
into her own hands with these large bags
of blood this seems to confirm that they
are in the hospital and this could be
for a few reasons one doris's pregnancy
or two alma herself we last saw doris
watching her daughter eat a squirrel in
the cemetery i wouldn't be surprised if
doris then takes her there or this
triggers something in which she'll have
to go to the hospital she's also been
feeling sick lately so that's a
possibility too alma remarks that she's
thirsty last episode she took one of
those black pills so she's running low
on those essential minerals her body so
desperately needs minerals which can
best be obtained by drinking blood we
see some vfx of the black pill and a
tweet by angelica ross who plays the
chemist confirms that she will be in
this episode here we have what appears
to be austin's rolls-royce pulling up to
bel noir's house we know this is near
bel noir's place by the route 6a marker
and white picket fence harry comes home
with a backpack slung around his
shoulder a little shocked to see someone
or something and i'm actually pretty
stumped here at what it could be the
last we saw him was in an entirely
different getup killing someone
underneath the dick dock so it looks
like harry knows alma took one of those
pills as he tells her never to get her
own blood he'll bring it to her there's
a little bit of editing trickery here as
the scene where he pours blood into a
bowl is different than the one where
they have their conversation here in the
muse restaurant we know it's hairy here
because of the watch and ring oma is
also wearing this very interesting white
robe i get all sorts of warming up on a
cold winter's day vibe with some fresh
hot blood ursula arrives unannounced
surprising harry this piece of cloth
suggests he may have been cleaning
something or hiding something mccully
culkin's mickey gets in a fight with a
random man on the beach and here we see
mickey feasting on his blood he took a
black pill last episode too we'll see
mickey visit the dick dock where it
appears he finds the victim he'll later
duke it out with on the beach the body
of mickey's victim can be seen here and
a badge in the top left corner suggests
that chief burleson will be on the case
honestly i haven't been too happy with
her police work harry's family was
scared by a pale one and harry murdered
someone in his home and she's just like
oh they're just crack addicts what can
you do it's no surprise this is what
will end up happening to her we also
don't know what happened to the body of
harry's victim he killed in episode 2 or
if that will be explored at all if the
dick dock is in provincetown he's
already broke one of belle noire's rules
never kill anyone in p-town here we have
a shot we've seen from the season
preview of austin and belle noire
pulling a gun on someone in the preview
it cuts to harry here but in this
preview it does not ursula and mickey
are at the muse and she wants to know
what the hell is going on in this town
mickey looks a little bit cocky here
like he's not going to tell her anything
this is different than the preview
footage where we can see him visibly
afraid of her so ursula might have
something on him we also know mickey is
an aspiring screenwriter and ursula
represents screenwriters so that could
come into play as well that's it for
this quick video make sure to toss it a
like and check out my other content for
more bad takes you can always follow me
on twitter and instagram at thingstoryt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much